of course Pete I am sorry for the the
pain as I say the anguish and the
heartbreak of so many people in this
country and by the way there are there
are people across government at every
level who have been going through
exactly the same privations and and
difficulties and of course we we all
understand that and Anais that all I'm
saying to you is that I think that what
we need to do now as competitions as
leaders if we possibly can is to set
aside this rile because I'm afraid a lot
of the allegations turned out to the
totally false and to move on I've said
what I've had to say about the matter i
I think that insofar as it is correct to
say that it is a distraction then by
that very argument now is the time to
leave it aside and a move on this is
just growing and growing prime minister
the anger is reaching a fever pitch
rating the zone just looks like petulant
devices no good in the nation you know
that eventually you will have to let me
go if I don't you know just get on with
it Prime Minister Pete thank you so much
for your point I consider that to be a
very it's a valuable piece of your
making up a political point in a piece
of political advice I consider that this
government what it is government needs
to do is is focus I don't on the needs
of the nation on sorting out this
problem and on getting our message
across and that's what we're going to do